we are all capable of good and bad no
matter which side of the barrier we come
from hey does he know just how much you
love The Descendants franchise you met
the love of your life on it set and you
made some lifelong friendships that
you'll always hold dear we were excited
to find out that you don't think this
story is over just yet you're a girl now
still has so much to give and fans still
have so many questions so tell us the
truth stub
what kind of spin-offs are headed our
way The Descendants franchise is far
from over and it's only a matter of time
before Kenny Ortega announces a brand
new project dubbed Cameron made it
crystal clear that she's still involved
with the franchise and that she's not
ready to say goodbye to mal just yet
watch until the end to find out about
Malin Ben's royal wedding and whether or
not we'll get to see it on the small
screen Duff Cameron may have moved on
from the Disney Channel but she isn't
done with it for good during an
interview with Digital Spy dove revealed
that she would be open to reprising her
role as mal Duff said that she may or
may not have heard that she might be
doing something involving the franchise
this vague statement came through loud
and clear Duff will be donning her
purple wig at some point or another but
for what reason we'll reveal the number
one reason why dub Cameron will be
returning to the descendents franchise
at the end of this video but first let's
take a look at some of the other
possible spin-off stuff hinted at during
her interview live-action TV series
during the same interview Duff revealed
that she thinks it would be smart for
Disney to capitalize on The Descendants
brand and we couldn't agree more anyone
who loves Disney's descendants has
probably made it a point to watch the
animated series descendants wicked world
well we think that a live-action
spin-off of this TV series would become
a fan favorite overnight while leading
ladies like Deb Cameron china anne
mcclain and Sophia Carson wouldn't be
involved in a live-action descendants TV
show brand new actors surely would the
Disney Channel could cast a whole new
set of teenage descendants and built a
TV series around them attending auradon
prep we
Malus clean things would change in
auradon for good students would learn to
use magic at school and we'd get to meet
a whole new wave of descendants we
really hope this spin-off idea comes to
fruition a brand new storyline the
descendants franchise follows my lead II
Carlos and J as they try to learn the
ropes in auradon but now that the core
four are all grown up there's a chance
that the Disney Channel will choose to
revamp the entire storyline and what
better way to do that than to focus on
the descendants of our favorite
descendants with the help of writer
Melissa de la Cruz Disney Channel
executives could create three new movies
that follow the children of mal Evie
Carlos and Jay as they attend auradon
prep the first film could start with
Mouse daughters coronation we would love
to see the court for his descendants
saving the United States of auradon from
its newest threat you never know grandma
Maleficent might even pay her
granddaughter a visit descendants for
dub Cameron believes that the
descendents franchise has a lot more
life in it beyond the third film this
has us thinking that descendants four
could become a reality and that most of
the cast would be interested in
reprising their roles but what exactly
would descendants or be about it's
possible that the fourth installment
would kick off with mal and Ben's royal
wedding and then go on to focus on the
merging of the Isle and Oregon despite
all the positive changes that happened
at the end of d3 there are tons of
villains who want revenge for having
been locked up in poor conditions for
over twenty years one of them being
mouse very own mother
Maleficent if the Disney Channel were to
produce descendants for we're pretty
sure it would focus on Ben and mal
learning to keep their Kingdom see from
those who wish to harm it before the
core for another potential spin-off
could take place in the past instead of
the future it would be so interesting to
see the events that led to the villains
being locked up by beasts and fairy
godmother we would love to see mal evj
and Carlos his parents cross paths
on the Isle of the Lost for the first
time this spinoff could also shine a
light on who evj and Carlos's missing
parents are it could focus on Hades and
Maleficent love story and reveal the
real reason they chose to call it quits
[Music]
this spinoff would be a fresh take on
the franchise allowing us to see the
younger versions of our favorite Disney
villains the royal wedding during her
interview with Digital Spy Dov revealed
that the descendants franchise never
ends she said that it goes on forever
and that the possibilities are endless
she also cunningly revealed that she
would be doing something involving the
franchise and we're pretty sure she's
talking about reprising her role as
mouth to give fans the royal wedding
they all deserves malla is all set to
become the queen of auradon but this
highly anticipated wedding never found
its way to the small screen and that is
just a shame so we wouldn't be surprised
at the descendants cast reunites one
more time to deliver the royal wedding a
descendent short story which one of
these spin-offs would you be most
interested in sound off in the comments
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up if you love descendants
and don't forget to subscribe to the
thing so you never miss another video
we'll catch you later
[Music]